be careful this christmas
rochford district community safety
partnership csp
is encouraging residents to help reduce
burglaries by leaving a light on when no
one is at home during the dark winter
evenings a home without lights on and
curtains left open could be an
invitation to the opportunistic burglar
officers warn it advertises that no one
is at home
rochefort district commander and chair
of the csp chief inspector glenn westley
said our message to residents at this
time of the year is simple get switched
on and leave a light on an empty house
is an attractive target for thieves if
you're going to be out all day at night
or going on holiday set timers for one
or more lights to come on when it gets
dark
automatic time switches are not
particularly expensive and are available
for most diy retailers
there are a number of steps you can take
to keep your home safe during the winter
months
check all doors and windows are shut
and locked before leaving your home is a
really useful routine to establish
some 3 out of 10 burglaries are
committed using open doors or windows
security lights which sense motion are
particularly valuable at front doors as
well as over paths at the side of the
property
a padlock on all side gates add to an
opportunist burglars annoyance
make sure any makeshift ladders such as
wheelie bins are not stored at the front
of your property
make sure if you have a pvc door that
the handle is fully lifted up and the
door locked with the key
drink driving the facts
beware of the morning after if you've if
you're out celebrating in the run-up to
christmas
the body takes an hour to process one
unit of alcohol so if you've had a heavy
night drinking you could still be over
the limit the next morning and in no fit
state to drive to work or tackle the
school run
to recover fully from the effects of a
heavy night of drinking you should avoid
alcohol for a further 48 hours
legally the alcohol limit for drinking
and driving is 80 milligrams of alcohol
per 100 milliliters of blood
that means drinking two pints of normal
strength beer or one large glass of wine
could put you over the limit
take a chance and get behind the wheel
and you risk at least a year's ban a
fine of up to five thousand pounds even
six months in prison
either way you will end up with a
criminal record and that could cost you
your job it will certainly bump up your
insurance premium
more seriously you could kill or injure
someone face up to 14 years in prison
and have to live with it on your
conscience for the rest of your life
myths
a cup of strong coffee will sober me up
caffeine is a stimulant so although it
might make you more alert it won't make
you sober i'll be fine to drive after a
cold shower
a cold shower might be refreshing but it
won't remove alcohol from your system
if i just drink beer and avoid the hard
stuff like spirits i'll be okay
alcohol is alcohol regardless of how you
drink it
keep tag tags on your bike
a bike isn't just for christmas if you
take appropriate steps to safeguard it
from theft
with this in mind rayleigh and rochford
neighborhood watch are planning a
special security tagging session early
in the new year
it will be held at raley library
saturday the 7th of january 2012 between
10 am and 12 noon
the service is free and the tags have
been provided by the rochefort district
community safety partnership
chair of the nhw mike hooper said this
is an ideal opportunity for anyone
buying or expecting to receive a bike
this christmas to come along and have it
fitted with a tag
the individually coded electronic tags
are implanted in the bike's frame and
each owner will be given a special cycle
passport with the code which is also
registered on a national database
this allows police to identify any
recovered bikes and return them to their
owners
stickers can also be attached to the
bike identifying them as having been
tagged as an additional deterrent to
thieves
neighborhood watch with the support of
the csb hold regular bike security
sessions across the district and this
year so far have fitted almost 250
devices
and now for details of our poster design
competition
nobody deserves to be picked on abused
or even assaulted simply because they're
different
but in today's diverse society people
are being victimized because of their
disability ethnic background religion
gender or sexual orientation
it may simply be the use of an
inappropriate and insensitive word or
phrase
at the other extreme it might be far
more serious this is known as hate crime
hate crime takes many forms verbal
insults abusive gestures bullying
offensive graffiti the sending of
malicious letters and text messages
abusive phone calls physical assaults
and even arson
the rochford district hate crime panel
has been set up to promote awareness of
this danger and works with many
different organizations to change
people's attitude to others
the panel has launched a poster design
competition aimed at reaching victims of
hate crime
depending on your age we need your help
to create an a4 poster or a logo that
encourages anyone subjected to hate
abuse to come forward and report it
whether to the police the council
school or bodies such as victim support
now to enter you must be at least 11
years of age and no older than 18 years
of age and there are two age categories
11 to 14 year olds design a logo that
the panel can use on leaflets posters
and displays to encourage victims to get
help
and 15 to 18 years old design an a4
poster for display in public places and
buildings around the district
so people know where and how to report
hate crime
prizes will be awarded to the winning
entries in both age groups
first prize a 50-pound amazon voucher
second prize 25 pounds amazon voucher
and third prize at 10 pounds amazon
voucher
entries must be submitted by monday the
9th of january 2012 at 12 noon
your entry must include your name age
home address telephone contact number
and email address if you have one
you can enter via email to paula.chapman
at rochford.gov dot uk
by post to community safety team
rochford district council council
offices
south street rochford ss4 1bw
the winners will be decided by members
of the hate crime panel who will judge
all the posters and logo designs
received by the closing date
the judge's decision will be final and
both the rochford district hate crime
panel and rochford district council
reserve the right to reproduce all
winning entries owning the copyright as
a condition of entry
entries will not be returned and
therefore please take a copy before you
submit your entry if you wish
dispersal order update
reported incidents of antisocial
behavior in hockley have dropped by
almost a half following the introduction
of a dispersal order covering large
areas of the town the order came into
effect on monday july the 11th to help
curb anti-social behavior and nuisance
and is a joint initiative involving the
police rochford district council and
rochford community safety partnership
the order allows police to disperse
groups of two or more people gathered
within the designated areas which
include maryland's nature reserve
plumber mount and the grounds of
betswood community centre
anyone refusing to leave when asked by
officers or who return within 24 hours
commits an offence and can be arrested
sergeant steve jones from the rochford
west neighborhood policing team said the
order is an excellent means of dealing
with potential incidents before they
escalate and has proven extremely
effective
rochford district council's portfolio
holder for community safety and vice
chairman of the community safety
partnership councillor joe mcpherson
added
this is very encouraging news and the
success of the dispersal order
underlines the power of partnership
working in helping to maintain law and
order in our community
dispersal order figures
in the three months to september police
dealt with 64 reports of antisocial
behaviour in hockley 55 fewer than the
same period in 2010
officers have used their dispersal
powers on 76 separate occasions over the
three months
partnership visits rayleigh
rayleigh residents had the opportunity
to learn more about the services offered
by organizations working in their area
at an information day held at the
women's institute hall bellingham lane
in september
the event was one of a number of days
organized by the castle point and
rochefort community development
partnership across the district
throughout the year
the event brought together a number of
local organizations including the
community safety partnership represented
by tracy schneider and paula chapman
look out for more information day events
in rochford district matters next year
rochford district matters is edited by
patrick john and produced by rochford
district council who can be found at
3-19 south street rochford ss41bw
their telephone number is 01702-546366
and their website is at www.rochford.gov
dot uk
the paper is printed by shaman and
company limited
and that brings us to the end of this
edition which was recorded by volunteers
from the rayleigh rochford and castle
point newspapers for the blind at their
studio in rochford